the january trading frenzy of certain
stocks has come under intense scrutiny
as
legislators regulators and others try to
understand what drove the rapid rise and
fall
of these securities gamestop shares in
particular
surge from about 20 to 483
over two weeks in january the price has
since fallen to around 45
the securities and exchange commission
is reviewing the volatility
the department of justice has launched a
probe and the commodity futures trading
commission has opened a preliminary
investigation into certain circumstances
of the rally
also the house financial services
committee is reviewing if the actions of
brokerages and online communities
require more oversight
central to these lines of inquiry are
questions of market manipulation
and the actions brokerages took in
response to the rally
but understanding whether these actions
cross the line takes time
and isn't always easy to determine
market manipulation in a nutshell is a
scheme
to create some kind of an artificial
price
so you can you can do that different
ways
there are different tactics that traders
can use to try to
artificially pump up the price of the
stock and then benefit
by selling into this sort of
frenzy that they've created dave
michaels covers white-collar crime and
financial enforcement for the wall
street journal
and says market manipulation schemes
have been going on as long as there's
been a market
some are quite time tested meaning
meaning they've been going on for a long
time
and regulators know the recipe and they
know sort of the telltale signs
a well-known example of market
manipulation is the stratton oakmont
pump and dump scheme of the early 90s
dramatized in the movie the wolf of wall
street it involved convincing investors
to bet large sums of money on a stock
inflating the price before stratton
brokers sold shares held by the firm and
its partners
what this trade will do is serve as a
benchmark for
future business kids you feel
comfortable with me now scott carey
curtis axel is a former assistant u.s
attorney
and former staff attorney at the sec
your typical
market manipulation case involves false
statements
by people who somehow want to manipulate
the stock price for their own gain
that's your typical kind of pump and
dump scheme
these false statements can come in the
form of brokers pushing inflated
financial outlooks
or bad actors publishing press releases
with outlandish claims of business
breakthroughs
some commentators have said individuals
coordinating on reddit
largely in the wall street bets forum
openly engaged in a pump and dump scheme
to inflate the price of gamestop
and other securities these allegations
have not come from regulators or law
enforcement
the cftc is looking into whether
misconduct occurred as reddit traders
targeted silver futures and the largest
exchange-traded fund tied to silver
the i-share silver trust but in an
anonymous public forum like reddit
determining the identity of users and
whether their posts were intended to
deceive
others may not be so clear-cut the sec
is a law enforcement agency
and it can seek records from reddit
that would reveal the people behind
these usernames
they would do that by sending a subpoena
for records
to reddit and reddit could agree
to comply with the subpoena and just
hand the records over on the other hand
there are some limitations that the sec
places frankly on itself in terms of
subpoenaing
news agencies or news media and one
question
may be is reddit sort of operating
um in a sense as a news site
and could it put up a first amendment
argument against the subpoena
actions taken by brokerages have also
caught the attention of regulators
the sec's acting chair allison lee told
npr that the agency is also looking into
whether decisions to curb trading at the
peak of the frenzy complied with
regulations
and specifically it's looking at
the reasons that the brokers gave so you
know
it wants to kick the tires on these
explanations and make sure that they're
true
when volatility goes up uh
clearing houses which are an
organization that sort of
uh they sort of collectively share the
risk
of trades defaulting or not happening in
the stock market
those clearinghouses said to the brokers
you need to give us more cash to cover
the risk
some of these brokers couldn't
immediately
provide all the cash that the
clearinghouse wanted and so
the only way to limit that call for cash
or margin
call was to limit new purchases
uh of gamestop federal prosecutors have
subpoenaed information from brokers such
as robin hood
and the brokerage is facing more than 30
civil lawsuits in relation to the
trading restrictions
i am sure that the sec and finra will be
going through their rule books to
determine if
if there were violations of the rules of
course
broker dealers such as robin hood are
claiming that the very reason they had
to halt trading was to comply with the
sec rules
so they may have a very good defense
that what they did was within their
customer agreements that allows them to
stop trading for any reason
experts say the outcomes of these
investigations are not likely to come
soon but the influence of social media
communities adds a new dimension to
trading that will likely receive
more scrutiny there's going to be this
initial flurry of activity
congress will hold hearings you know
they will want to assuage the public
by taking some initial testimony and
looking like they're doing something
but the hard work of making any change
in this area will likely take some time
at least through the games the lens of
gamestop it seems
like social media is becoming a bigger
influencer
of investment decisions that does change
how
how markets behave at least occasionally
at least with respect to
certain stocks it's it's not something
that they can completely ignore